[Musica]
se 15 anni fa quando tutto il tutto dei
social intendo
in Italia l'ossessione per Facebook
Comincia proprio lì 2008 Ecco se ci
avessero detto quindici anni fa
che questi grossi giocattoli
dell'internet di lì a poco
avrebbero cambiato un po' tutto cioè
avrebbero cambiato la politica il modo
di fare politica la propaganda il modo
di conoscerci il modo di tradirci il
modo di incontrarci che avrebbero
cambiato la stampa che avrebbero
cambiato la pubblicità che avrebbero
cambiato coi filtri anche le nostre
facce Ecco se ce l'avessero detto non ci
avremmo creduto erano quello erano
grossi giocattoli di internet quindi sei
anni dopo siamo Le cavie di questo
grande esperimento E certo
la cavia non è la più adatta a parlare
dell'esperimento Ma lo faremo lo stesso
meglio delle lunghe dissertazioni
secondo me secondo tutti i buoni esempi
quindi cominciamo da lì da una storia
questa
li riconoscete tutti
inizio del primo decennio del nuovo
millennio erano la Premiere coppia
francese Holland trierweiler presidente
lui giornalista molto nota lei
si spezza la favola più o meno nel 2014
fine 2013 di lì a poco la nuova compagna
di online diventerà Jolie Gray attrice
poche pochissime dichiarazioni di
Valerie Trial poche settimane dopo
l'annuncio tutti ci speravano da una
parte tutti lo temevano dall'altra la
signora treerviler avrebbe pubblicato un
memoir
donna ferita presidente
mimoire lei è una giornalista fate voi
l'addizione
bene
grande attesa in Francia per il libro di
Valeria
passano le settimane aumenta l'attesa
arriviamo al giorno dell'uscita del
libro
una mattina Quella mattina
un signor nessuno
passeggiava per l'orien un paese del
nord della Francia
sulla vetrina di una libreria c'era quel
cartello che vedete
noi non abbiamo il libro di Valerie
seguiva una faccina sorridente
non abbiamo il libro di Valeria
che succede a quel tweet 160 caratteri e
una foto
quel tweet diventa virale sapete cosa
vuol dire virale quando si parla dei
social network
lo leggono tutti lo vedono tutti fa il
giro del mondo questa foto fa il giro
del mondo bene
virale Può voler dire anche due cose un
bel destino Fortunato se ti va bene se
hai scritto qualcosa di intelligente
la tua Apocalisse personale Se ti
dovesse andare molto male
dopo questo cartello all'orient la
stessa mattina cominciano a fiorire per
tutta la Francia cartelli che dicono noi
non abbiamo il libro di valerity revival
però abbiamo Balzac abbiamo un abbiamo
tutta la letteratura francese cosa si
capisce che è una piccola rivolta
privata della letteratura altissima
francese siamo contro questi meymore
Noi siamo per l'alta letteratura e
questo che si intende
solo poche settimane dopo qualcuno pensa
di fare la sola cosa che c'era
intelligente da fare
cioè intervistare il libraio di Lorient
domanda
Ma lei perché ha messo quel cartello
quella mattina
perché era la terza persona che entrava
e che chiedeva il libro e il libro
sarebbe arrivato soltanto nel pomeriggio
Quindi lei lo avrebbe venduto Sì
Certamente
perché questa esondazione è un racconto
interessante perché spiega i social
vedete le nostre parole sui social
possono smettere di appartenerci
scivolano come le saponette diventano
indipendenti anche dalle nostre
intenzioni la rassegna stampa di quel
libro diventò quella quel giorno il
giorno dell'uscita
come siamo arrivati fin qui E dov'è qui
la definizione Intanto è di timoraili
un editore irlandese
che
qualche decennio fa intuisce e Conia
l'espressione internet 2.0
cos'era internet 1.0 chi c'era e ha più
di 40 anni se lo ricorda era una specie
di grossa pentola andavamo e pescavamo
un'informazione inviavamo una mail
servivano approfondimento ed era lì che
lo trovavamo Ma comunque era fruizione
passiva eravamo pure un po'
vergognose di stare sui social
poi che succede
questi Social hanno cominciato a
crescere e ammontare fino a diventare
quello che Baricco definisce nel suo the
game un oltre mondo
un posto da abitare colonizzare un posto
dove se tutto va bene a Zuckerberg
abiteremo con i nostri Avatar
Ecco questo oltremondo è il posto dove
siamo adesso login e logout non si
riconoscono più si è perso il tasto Noi
siamo quelli dentro oltre a essere
quelli fuori
erano due cose distinte e distanti il
mondo offline e il mondo online
si dice
ed è corretto
che quando qualcosa ha le carte per
toccare le due cittadines espugnabili
del diritto cioè il diritto di famiglia
matrimonio separazione divorzio e il
diritto del lavoro
quel qualcosa merita molta attenzione
bene
diritto del lavoro
tutte o quasi tutte le società Adesso
hanno dei regolamenti disciplinari per
l'uso dei social
post in accorti possono costare un posto
di lavoro
dall'ultima ricerca Kaspersky otto su
dieci vorrebbero cancellare qualcosa che
hanno scritto nel 2021 e molti di noi
hanno avuto o hanno problemi per post
pubblicati sui social network e
attenzione
regolamento aziendale sull'uso dei
social network vuol dire che stiamo
andando a toccare a comprimere la
libertà di espressione
la libertà di espressione è
costituzionalmente garantita è una
grossa crepa o un inizio di una grossa
crepa nel sistema
diritto di famiglia
vi dico che non esiste più un solo
fascicolo in tribunale per separazione o
per divorzi che non porti al suo interno
materiale tra le prove
preso dai dispositivi elettronici chat
foto su Instagram varie
è talmente radicato l'uso dei social
nelle nostre relazioni che adesso il più
famoso tipo di relazione è lo scriversi
senza vedersi Non ridete perché non
stanno ridendo in Cassazione Ecco in
Cassazione adesso l'organo supremo
della Giustizia si decide se scriversi
senza vedersi sia tradimento o no
dipende è la risposta la magistratura è
spaccata però capite bene che se un
problemuccio nato sui social cioè le
relazioni scritte è discusso in
Cassazione qualcosa si è incrinato
e quindi
collezione dei guai reso conto delle
disgrazie inventario di quello che ci
hanno portato i social tutto negativo
hanno inquinato la politica hanno
inquinato il modo di fare politica ci
hanno inquinato le teste si parla di
switch cost Effect quella fatica di cui
tutti ci lamentiamo da dieci anni a
questa parte Secondo molti altro non è
che stanchezza dei neuroni Cioè per
stare appresso Alle notifiche facciamo
fatica a tornare a fuoco Sul lavoro
switch cost Effect poi hanno rovinato le
relazioni hanno rovinato i matrimoni
hanno rovinato la stampa hanno rovinato
la pubblicità che altro hanno rovinato
noi
e quindi
è tutto a perdere
si butta tutto
o qualcosa è salvabile perché ci deve
essere qualcosa di salvabile
tu sapevi scrivere o sapevi suonare il
pianoforte meglio di Glenn Gold o sapevi
cantare o sapevi recitare e però vivevi
sulla cima di una montagna in provincia
di Benevento Chi l'avrebbe saputo
nessuno
ora chi può saperlo tutti
si dice e anche in questo caso è
corretto se sai fare qualcosa
Mettila dove qualcuno possa vederla
non sai qui Se più o meno 10 anni fa un
direttore di giornale avesse letto un
paio di frasi per caso quando non ero
nessuno né online né offline e mi avesse
detto prova era un avvocato
probabilmente sarei rimasta solo un
avvocato e invece il sogno di quando ero
piccola mi è venuto a prendere per mano
il posto giusto
la cosa giusta e il momento giusto tutto
a portata di mano vedete Quanto possono
diventare
democratici gli accessi a certi colpi di
fortuna
e noi stiamo lasciando però che la nuova
generazione
Pensi che i social siano soltanto
autoscatti filtri e la possibilità di
fare molti soldi vendendo qualche Tisana
dimagrante il posto giusto il momento
giusto a portata di mano per tutti
se vi sembra poco a me francamente No
grazie
[Applauso]